all right oh my facebook link I closet
me the door
it's saturday afternoon in downtown
Hamburg and German fans are getting
ready for the match against Ghana
there are countless world cup souvenirs
on sale in the German national colors
the German fans are proud of their team
and since Germany hosted the world cup
in 2006 they don't mind showing it
what better place to watch the game than
a public viewing venue for example at
this Hamburg beer garden
bubbly viewing this fan says public
viewing is a great way to enjoy live
football you mind watching football with
others is great if you're sitting alone
at home you can't share the moment it is
you're not alone with your worries you
can really enjoy the game with a lot of
other people it's great perfect excel is
also looking forward to the germany
ghana game but first he wants to put
three locals runs our towels and yen's
to the test how much do they know about
the world cup though become it's time
now for our euromaxx world cup test we
met Brazilian fans in Berlin Italian
fans and Naples and English supporters
in London the Italians have a clear lead
so far think you can beat them the
German fans are confident they can beat
them hands down first it's time for some
gold practice each candidate has three
shots and each goal schools a point
a mere two goals for the German fans
cambia to its fine now it's time for the
second round our world cup quiz it's
quite simple I ask you questions about
the Germans squad three questions three
points for every right answer you're
allowed to confer noise so question one
which player has scored the most goals
the torch knutson are mine shaft closer
with 14 goals Xandra agrees slatter but
you're both wrong it's get Miller looks
like they need to brush up on their
World Cup general knowledge they can
plan and how did germany do at the 2006
world clouds and six by devi Emma magnet
lands good coach they came third after
beating Portugal and struck out HD well
done 3 points team now how often did
germany make it through to the world cup
final innovate meisterschaft 8286 19 but
what do you think seven times see
another right answer
time now to set up the final round so
far the German fans have scored eight
out of a possible 27 points but in the
final round they could score another
nine points they have to recognize three
members of today's team from Ghana the
faces have to match the jerseys
but sadly they only managed to get one
player right and even fail to recognize
Garner's star kicker kevin-prince
boateng it's movie so I'm afraid you
only managed to score 11 points so you
didn't manage to beat the Italians
medium schlanger tahyna had only saw
guns from junior because it's not
realistic we're going to win the World
Cup Italy is almost out England's been
sent home and Brazil's not playing very
well either so we're going to win that's
reality you get used to be led but the
poor result doesn't spoil the day for
the fans and Excel is also rooting for
the German team
three thousand fans have turned up at
the biergarten in Hamburg to watch the
match against Ghana the Germans are tips
to win
but the match ends in a draw Germany is
definitely in World Cup fever and the
poor results in today's euromaxx test
won't change that but most people here
thought Germany would have an easy time
beating ghana and they were disappointed
with the final score woodsy phylum and
under the ticket misc Avenged